if you've been anxiously awaiting for an  outlast game to scare you again I've got  good news I'm Tony this is a GameSpot  news update and to keep up with every  jump-scare be sure to subscribe  outlast - puts you in the shoes of  journalist Blake Langerman as he and his  wife Lynne investigate a creepy town in  the Arizona desert you'll be able to  start your investigation on April 25th  on ps4 Xbox one and PC both on disk and  via digital download also coming on  April 25th is outlast Trinity a disk  based collection of outlast one it's  whistleblower DLC and outlast 2 so you  have some options for getting creeped  out next month in other outlast 2 news  the game will not feature VR support at  least not at launch but if you want some  horror that does incorporate VR check  out the debut episode of our new show  reboot it's all about Resident Evil 7  and to keep up with all the scariest  game news you're already in the right  place  [Music]  you